[موسيقى]
انتم تدرون ان النجوم التي نشاهدها الان
على صفحه السماء اغلبها غير موجود وفيه
نجوم موجوده بالسماء لكن ما بعد شفناه الى
هالحين ليش لان خبر وفاته او ولادته ما
بعد وصلنا الى هالحين لبعد المسافه
فالنجوم تبعد عنا بعدا سحيقا وهذه المسافه
تقاس بالسنين الضوئيه فالسنه الضوئيه
الواحده هي المسافه التي يقطعها الضوء
لمده سنه كامله وهو يسير بمسافه 300 الف
كيلومتر بالثانيه تخيل هالمسافه هذه وبعده
على سبيل التمثيل سهيل يبعد عنه 310 سنه
ضوئيه بمعنى انه الان نشاهد سهيل خلال هذه
الايام وترى ضوءه مرسله عام 1134 هجري
1713 ميلادي في سهيل الان نش موقعه لا
نشاهد ضوءه فلا اقسم بمواقع النجوم وانه
لقسم لو تعلمون عظيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فالاجرام السماويه تبعد عنا بعدا سحيقا ان
الكواكب في علو محلها لترى صغارا وهي غير
صغاري والنجوم لها حياه كحياه الانسان
تولد وتترعرع وتموت تولد من رحم الكون
وتخنس وتموت وتكنس في مقابرها اللي هي
الثقوب السوداء فلا اقسم بالخنس الجوار
الكنس والليل اذا عسعس والصبح اذا تنفس
[موسيقى]